rugby le case de jean pierre rives
réalise le grand chelem pologne les
nouvelles grèves complique gravement la
situation dit moscou les jurés de nevers
suivre le réquisitoire perpétuité pour
les meurtriers du gendarme yves montand
à l'olympia le 9 octobre
il nous l'a confié dans l'antenne de
midi madame mademoiselle monsieur
bonsoir 21 mars 1980 et oui c'est la
date d'aujourd'hui c'est pour tous ceux
qui jouent au rugby ou plus simplement
qu'ils aiment regarder un match de rugby
à la télévision et bien cette huile date
historique à twickenham cet après midi
l'équipe de france commandée par jean
pierre rives a battu l'angleterre 16
points à 12 et sur la pelouse du temple
du rugby britannique
les français ont non seulement remporté
le tournoi des cinq nations édition 1980
mais pour la troisième fois de leur
histoire après 1968 et 1977
ils ont réalisé le grand chelem qui
aurait pu penser cela au début de la
saison les rouges et qui comprend tacle
contre attaque poliment d'ailleurs ils
ont rencontré ya qu'à berne et il va
tuer l'enfant dans but
troisième grand chelem paulo 28 77 83 m
la france bat l'angleterre à twickenham
face perd deux points à 12 puis canam il
est 17h30 dans le couloir qui conduit au
vestiaire tv secal sobre voici jean
pierre rives
il savoure la plus belle réussite de sa
carrière tout a été vite très vite
tout s'est joué au cours de la première
mi-temps prive encourage ses partenaires
un vent très fort souffle sur twickenham
il est défavorable aux anglais pour les
français c'est au cours des 40 premières
minutes de la rencontre qu'il faut faire
la différence
13e minute une faute sur une
introduction en mêlée des anglais une
pénalité pour la france berbizier sait
déjà qu'il va passer le ballon la porte
la france mène 3 0
un troisième minute le seul domaine dans
lequel l'angleterre a dominé la france
la touche
les anglais à l'attak une balle
récupérée par dow un long coup de pied
toujours le vent favorable
l'arrière anglais rose dégage
tranquillement en touche regard de ses
22 mètres il ignore que la berbie j'ai
récupéré le ballon à jouer la touche
très rapidement ne s'est pas encore
retourné que la touche a déjà été jouée
berbizier a lancé et l'accord bâle et
c'est l'opportunisme de berbizier la
france mail
9 à 0 35e minute mais les primes
10 berbizier pas récupéré le ballon
crochète berbizier à gauche à droite une
balle converture bertranne perdre au
dernier quand on ne voit pas ça par don
13 à 0 pour l'enfant
on revoit cet esprit berbizier
ouverture de berbizier bertranne
regarder pardo pardo va revenir sur la
gauche de codorniou passe de codorniou
en se retournant
41e minute de la rencontre berbizier
percussions des avants français
berbizier à nouveau la porte
la france mène 16 à 0 les anglais ne
revinrent au cou
victoire de la france 16 à 12 oui et une
victoire est donc un grand chelem
monsieur giscard d'estaing a adressé il
ya quelques minutes un télégramme à jean
pierre rives veuillez partager mon cher
capitaine avec chacun de vos camarades
mais très chaleureuses félicitations
pour le grand chelem que vous venez de
remporter en apportant une brillante
démonstration de l'ardeur et de l'esprit
sportif français signé donc valéry
giscard d'estaing
dans l'autre match de cet après midi qui
comptait lui aussi pour le tournoi des
cinq nations merlas de l'autre côté du
classement pour la cuillère de bois
l'ecosse a battu l'irlande 10.9 c'est
donc pire landes qui recueille cette
année cette cuillère de bois
le maréchal soviétique viktor koulikov
commandant en chef des troupes du pacte
de varsovie est arrivé aujourd'hui en
allemagne de l'est le maréchal koulikov
bien supervisé les grandes manoeuvres du
pacte qui se déroule actuellement en
union soviétique en tchécoslovaquie en
rda et en pologne en pologne au
lendemain des graves incidents qui ont
opposé miliciens et syndicaliste le
gouvernement comme les dirigeants des
syndicats solidarité font tout pour
enrayer la menace qui pèse depuis jeudi
sur la paix sociale est peut-être sur la
paix tout court dans ce pays pour
monsieur walesa comme pour le général
jaruzelski à seul objectif aujourd'hui
faire redescendre la pression dans la
rue des blessés hier abitbol des blessés
pour la première fois depuis que l'on
parle du syndicat solidarité roselyne et
dernière
la police était intervenue brutalement
contre les membres de solidarité rurale
et depuis hier la tension monte la
situation s'aggravait d'heure en heure
menace de grève générale pour lundi dans
toute la pologne
mise en garde de la perf de varsovie le
gibier vaches avis disons que jamais les
choses n'avaient été aussi grave
mise en garde de l'agencé getty ctas
accusant les militants de solidarité
d'être responsable des incidents avec à
l'arrière-plan la menace implicite d'une
intervention celui qui mise en garde du
gouvernement des etats-unis est restée
l'urss pour le cas où elle songerait
intervenir en pologne
bref une crise de première grandeur avec
une fois de plus des craintes pour la
pologne voire pour la paix et une fois
de plus l'espoir renaît
pour solidarité monsieur walesa réclame
une négociation en même temps le
gouvernement de varsovie annonce qu'il
veut négocier une délégation
gouvernementale ira à bydgoszcz
et monsieur jean letaille demain
disputés à varsovie avec le vice premier
ministre monsieur rakowski cette fois
les frais de traiteurs de bischoff avec
l'eau et encore une fois on l'espère
tout ira bien qu'il finira bien est un
sport à condition qu'un nouvel incident
ne vienne remettre le feu aux poudres et
justement cet après midi quatre
chauffeurs d'autobus de varsovie ont été
malmenés puis brutalisés par des
miliciens
ces conducteurs coller des affiches
amical à propos des incidents de bits
grâce à l'intérieur de leurs dépôts
d'autobus une commission de la section
solidarité de varsovie s'est aussitôt
rendu sur place
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
c'est le verdict rendu cet après midi
par la cour d'assises de la nièvre
jean-luc della justyna et frédéric
landry meurtrier le 9 août 1977 d'un
gendarme ont été condamnés à la prison à
vie les jurés que ces rayons ont ainsi
suivi le réquisitoire de l'avocat
général qui hier s'était refusé à
demander la peine de mort oui je crois
qu'après six jours d'audiences
l'histoire judiciaire voudra sans doute
gardé un enseignement je dirais presque
une jurisprudence de ce procès ainsi
deux hommes qui traditionnellement
s'opposent dans les salles de cour
d'assises celui qui prononce le
réquisitoire qui demande une peine au
nom des lois de la république
et puis celui qui plaide celui qui
défend un homme fût-il le meurtrier d'un
policier vient ces deux hommes à nevers
se sont rejoints dans le même
raisonnement
hier l'avocat général didier joly
repoussait la peine de mort en
expliquant avec netteté qu'il nous
fallait savoir ne pas céder à l'opinion
publique ce matin l'avocat jean louis
pelletier si tu es en écho une phrase
célèbre arrière opinion publique arrière
du prétoire
elle n'est jamais que la prostituée qui
tire le juge par la manche
mais surtout m betty a su démontrer la
terrible loterie de la peine capitale
il est en effet également le défenseur
de philip morris condamné à mort
attendant la grâce sous la guillotine
dans une cellule de la prison de fresnes
philip morris avait tué un policier
jean-luc des lacs du stina a tué un
gendarme
l'un à paris fut condamné à mort l'autre
hanover il ya quelques heures était
condamné à la prison à perpétuité
ce soir il faut je crois
bien se rappeler ce qui fut dit dans le
réquisitoire de ce procès à nos verres
entre l'indulgence de jadis et la
rigueur implacable et parfois aveugle de
ces derniers mois il importe de suivre
une voie médiane de ses rayons vous
parliez à l'instant de philip morris se
condamner à mort qui attend dans sa
cellule de condamnés à mort la décision
du président de la république est bien
le frère de philippe maury jean jacques
maurice a été inculpé aujourd'hui de
complicité de tentative d'assassinât et
de complicité de tentative d'évasion il
est soupçonné d'avoir fait parvenir à
son frère par l'intermédiaire de son
avocate
le revolver avec lequel philip morris a
également blessé un surveillant de
prison il ya quelques semaines en images
d'un corps je propose de revenir sur ce
qui s'est passé dans notre pays est
depuis 24 heures en commençant par cet
accident de chemin de fer d'hier soir à
quelques centaines de mètres seulement
de la gare de bonnes bonnes dans la côte
d'or
ce convoi de carburant en flamme s'était
arrêtée hier soir au signal rouge près
de la gare de bonnes deux motrices pour
des raisons inconnues sont venus
percuter l'arrière du train les deux
conducteurs ont trouvé la mort dans
l'accident
il a fallu deux heures aux sauveteurs
pour venir à bout d'un incendie éviter
une catastrophe la fédération des
cheminots cgt met en cause
devant cette nouvelle collision l'état
des matériels sncf et la réduction des
effectifs
cinq petits cercueils des roses et des
os mobiles la dernière guerre découvert
dans la cour du presbytère du village
des familles statufié douleur et à
l'hôpital trois autres enfants blessés
par le projectile de mortiers dont là ce
soir est dans un état très grave
les lip des ménages ce week-end les 500
machines outils soigneusement entretenue
est gardée jour et nuit depuis huit ans
palente luz inoccupé depuis 59 moi c'est
fini
les locaux sont à vendre mais l'équipe
reste toujours en coopérative une
coopérative légal le déménagement
n'était demandée par les pouvoirs
publics
ils vont s'installer à deux kilomètres
de là dans une usine plus petit mais où
distille ils pourront être plus efficace
là ils n'assureront plus que le montage
des montres ils sont aujourd'hui un peu
moins de 200 en 1976 il était encore un
millier le journal des élections
présidentielles c'est demain que sera
publié au journal officiel le décret
convoquant les électeurs pour le
dimanche 26 avril un décret qui
précisera l'heure d'ouverture des
bureaux de vote de 8 heures à 18 heures
en général de 8h à 20h dans les grandes
villes et comme il faut que tout soit
prêt si le texte publié demain indique
également que le second tour s'il est
nécessaire d'y procéder aura lieu le
dimanche
les différents candidats à cette
élection présidentielle n'ont donc plus
que 35 jours pour persuader les
électeurs du bien fondé de leur thèse
et c'est ce que monsieur michel debré a
fait aujourd'hui en s'adressant aux
jeunes
250 jeunes délégués locaux de comités de
soutien les chefs de rayon ce matin
manifesté leur ferveur dans différents
quartiers de paris
il avait auparavant dit comment il
concevait l'éducation la formation la
participation et l'emploi thème que
devait reprendre marielle goitschel et
maurice druon mais seulement après une
longue pause pour regarder le match de
rugby tous deux aussi en mis l'accent
sur la rigueur morale de leur candidat
michel debré après un appel à ses
supporters et des mois c'est plus que je
me bats a vivement dénoncé le chômage
social et que d'abord il n'est pas vrai
qu'on le puisse à la fois lutter contre
ces deux cancers de notre société
inflation et chômage il n'est pas vrai
qu'il soit nécessaire de multiplier par
quatre ou cinq le nombre de chômeurs
pour contenir les hausses excessives de
salaires et de prix
je n'y peux les faillites en chaîne
tient lieu de politique inéluctable le
chômage est la conséquence d'une
politique erronée dans ses principes
détestable dans ses effets le chômage
massif des jeunes n'est pas un mal c'est
saunier justiciables chacal automne
d'une dose massive d'anesthésiques c'est
un problème comme on dit structurel et
durable
si aucune politique de redressement par
des économies par le travail par l'
épargne par la solidarité nationale ne
se décide non seulement à en atténuer la
gravité mais à le supprimer
monsieur chirac de son côté des tirs à
rouen l'ancien président du rpr s'est
attaqué à monsieur giscard d'estaing et
à monsieur mitterrand pour lui les deux
hommes ont tout intérêt en ce moment à
se retrouver face à face au second tour
cet après midi à paris monsieur chirac
céderait cette tour représentante de la
convention nationale des mouvements de
la gauche 5e république jean-louis la
scène
la convention nationale des mouvements
de la gauche 5e république qu'est ce que
c'est exactement et bien pour les
organisateurs de la réunion
d'aujourd'hui
mais une dizaine de groupuscules à la
lisière de la gauche et de la majorité
mais dont personne ne sait vraiment s'il
représente un véritable groupe de
pression ou non toujours est il que
jacques chirac a tenu à venir cet
après-midi pour recueillir le soutien de
ses dix mouvements
une façon comme une autre pour lui
d'obtenir une caution dit
à l'évidence cet après midi l'important
ce n'était pas tant l'influencé qu'ont
les mouvements représentait que le fait
qu'ils aient pull pour jacques chirac
siéger tous à la même tribune qu'il
s'agisse des gaullistes de gauche comme
les adhérents du msp le mouvement pour
le socialisme par la participation
dirigée par l'ancien ministre philippe
de chat ou de ce qu'on appelle les
radicaux chiraquiens comme jacqueline
bout l'ancien secrétaire général du
parti radical
or pourtant ils s'étaient tous là un
samedi après midi
réunis dans un grand hôtel de paris pour
écouter aussi bien le candidat chirac et
l'ancien aide de camp du général de
gaulle
l'amiral flohic et c'est peut-être cela
l'essentiel à propos de monsieur chirac
une critique de monsieur jean pierre
soisson le ministre de la jeunesse et
des sports monsieur jacques chirac se
refuse pour le deuxième tour à choisir
entre valéry giscard d'estaing et
françois mitterrand
c'est une position ambiguë dit monsieur
soissons qui estime d'ailleurs tout
aussi ambiguë le fait que françois
mitterrand n'est pas répondu à la
question qui lui était posée du choix
entre georges marchais et valéry giscard
d'estaing lui botte du côté de monsieur
georges marchais justement monsieur
marché qui sera lundi soir l'invité de
jean-pierre elkabbach d'alain duhamel
pour cartes sur table à 20h30 sur
antenne 2 et bien du côté de monsieur
marche est une interview qui sera
publiée demain par l'est républicain
pour le leader communiste il n'y a pas
de raison pour que l'urss voit d'un
mauvais oeil une expérience socialiste
en france est en tout cas a ajouté
monsieur georges marchais ce n'est ni à
washington ni à bonn ni à moscou que
doivent se régler les affaires de notre
pays reste la candidature de monsieur
françois mitterrand à ce propos monsieur
georges fillioud du parti socialiste
s'étonne que les deux émissions
télévisées auquel ont participé monsieur
giscard d'estaing et raymond barre et
était retransmise dès le lendemain de
leur diffusion par fr3 dans les dom tom
alors que le débat cartes sur table avec
françois mitterrand justement n'a pas
encore été diffusée à la guadeloupe et à
la règle mais la télévision justement
elle intéresse aussi certains
spécialistes qui
juge pas les candidats sur le fond sur
la proposition mais plus sur leurs
forces sur la forme sur leur langage
alors les lexicologue dafoe maîtrise et
jean-marie cotteret qui lui est
politologue et universités réalise en ce
moment même pour l'express une enquête
sur ce thème et jean-marie cotteret nous
a d'ailleurs expliqué ce qu'il avait
observé lors du dernier cartes sur table
avec françois mitterrand
oui je ferai trois observations
la première c'est que entre 1974 et 1981
le vocabulaire de françois mitterrand
n'a pratiquement pas évolué à
l'exception toutefois de deux mots le
mot chômage qui est un mode actualité et
le mot candidat sortant monsieur
mitterrand désigne son adversaire actuel
non plus par son nom mais par
l'expression candidat sortant deuxième
remarque monsieur mitterrand utilise
très peu le vocabulaire du parti
socialiste en effet on a étudié
systématiquement l'évolution du
vocabulaire du parti socialiste depuis
1945 et le vocabulaire est composé de
mots comme progrès action démocratique
ces mots ne font pas partie du
vocabulaire nationalité rang troisième
remarque elle concerne la
personnalisation du discours et là on
doit constater que parmi tous les
candidats qui sont en campagne
monsieur mitterrand est celui qui a le
plus fort indice de personnalisation
c'est à dire qu'ils utilisent le plus je
moi moi je près de 400 fois en une heure
au dernier cartes sur table qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire que
le candidat mitterrand de 80 est
différent de celui de 74 côté alors là
je vous répondrais selon qu'on a une
attitude optimiste ou une attitude
pessimiste
l'attitude optimiste c'est de dire qu'il
a un vocabulaire constant qui est dans
la ligne de son combat et la latitude
pessimiste c'est de dire tout simplement
qu'il n'a pas évolué
et puis dans ce débat électoral une
intervention celle d'yves montand
aujourd'hui dans un thème 2010 pour yves
montand qui parlait des prestations
télévisées des différents candidats
monsieur jacques chirac a fait un gros
impact
monsieur françois mitterrand est en
progrès et monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing brillant mais sans vouloir
s'engager personnellement dans la
campagne électorale actuelle
ils vont aussi donner un petit coup de
patte au parti de gauche qui ne
permettent pas aux petits partis aux
marginaux de s'exprimer puisque les
partis de gauche ne veulent pas soutenir
et parrainer leur candidature mais ce
midi
il monte en a pas parlé que politique il
a annoncé une grande nouvelle au
téléspectateur d'antenne 2 après treize
ans d'absence
yves montand va remonter sur scène cela
se passera en octobre prochain à
l'olympia
alors j'ai fait ma logique au le 9
octobre 1981 pour une durée de jeu croit
deux mois deux mois et demi à l'olympia
alors c'est officiel maintenant comme
utile si vous avez envie de vous visez
beaucoup de nouvelles chansons et goudé
quand je vois ce qu'on passe sur les
postes périphériques ou même sur france
inter arno passe des chansons que j'ai
enregistrée en 45 46 notamment comme les
grands boulevards je me dis je me
demande quels efforts je pourrais faire
dans ce domaine là bien sûr il y aura
des choses nouvelles mais ce sera
beaucoup plus une autre présentation
j'essaie si vous voulez d'arriver sur
scène en pour les jeunes de 20 ans que
ce soit pas du tout pour essayer de les
pendre parce que ça vous pouvez passer
de kilos venir vers vous et vous venez
pas essayer de quoi que ce soit de foot
dans tous les domaines qu'ils aient
l'impression de découvrir un champion
nouveau y compris pour les jeunes de ma
génération de annaba quelque chose de
nouveau tout en retrouvant le personnage
la journée internationale pour
l'élimination de la discrimination
raciale a été marquée aujourd'hui en
france par des états généraux de la
lutte contre le racisme en vue d'en
rechercher les causes de les comprendre
et surtout de les combattre
organisée à l'initiative du mrap le
mouvement contre le racisme et pour
l'amitié entre les peuples
les états généraux ont traité du racisme
en france et dans le monde notamment en
afrique du sud et en amérique du sud
une enquête du mrap fait apparaître un
racisme latent en france surtout à
l'égard des travailleurs immigrés des
tziganes et des juifs est indissociable
selon ce mouvement d'une politique
globale qui taxent de racisme d'état
et puis à l'occasion de cette même
journée de son côté de la ligue
internationale contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme c'est la licra a
préconisé des mesures de prévention et
aussi de pédagogie des préjugés de la
tolérance et des tentations raciste chez
les jeunes à l'or parmi des mesures qui
sont préconisées par la licra figure
l'enseignement de l'histoire des peuples
l'étude des persécutions racistes et des
génocides l'affichage et le commentaire
par les enseignants de la déclaration
des droits de la une fusillade a éclaté
ce matin à saint-jean-de-luz en plein
centre de la ville un homme a été blessé
cette fusillade serait une nouvelle
manifestation du bataillon basque
espagnol c'est une organisation
clandestine qui est opposé aux
séparatistes basques à réfugiés basques
espagnols a été blessées et une personne
de nationalité espagnole faisait
d'ailleurs bien partie du commando qui a
déclenché la fusillade a été arrêté à la
frontière entre l'espagne et la france
les contrôles ont été sérieusement
renforcées aujourd'hui 21 mars le
printemps c'était hier et aujourd'hui ce
samedi était consacrée à la journée
nationale de l'arbre ce matin en ouvrant
au public les haras de jardy jardiner
dans les hauts-de-seine
monsieur michel d'ornano le ministre de
l'environnement et du cadre de vie a
rappelé que depuis 30 ans la forêt
française avait progressé de plus de 3
millions d'hectares
alors pour monsieur dans l'anneau la
france est en train de gagner la
bataille de l'environnement à l'ouest de
paris à 10 kilomètres de la tour eiffel
le domaine des haras de jardy a été
ouvert au public aujourd'hui
fidèle à sa vocation ce domaine de 84
hectares accueillera en premier lieu un
centre équestre dans des bâtiments
anglo-normand du siècle dernier 30
tennis qui seront également construits
les promeneurs eurent profité vaudois et
dimanche ni pour les enfants jouent en
toute liberté
mais jouer on veut jouer à tomates s'en
sert mal aux mains depuis le bois de
boulogne depuis le bois de vincennes
ça sera la première fois qu'en quelques
années on aura ouvert pour les parisiens
les habitants de la région parisienne à
peu près 800 hectares d'espacés verts
visent les choses tout à fait
considérable et cela représentera
combien de park et bien ça représente de
très nombreux part je voudrais pas vous
les ir tout mais en fait y en a huit
principaux autour de paris ça veut dire
voyez vous voilà le printemps jésus à
une dizaine de dimanche de printemps est
bien que j'invite tous les gens de la
région parisienne à aller se promener
chaque dimanche dans un parc nouveau
qu'ils découvriront aux abords de la
région parisienne
autre réserve de nature ouverte au
public aujourd'hui mais au nord de paris
cette fois le parc foresti de sevran
ballon d'oxygène de cette zone fortement
urbanisée les 116 hectares de cette
ancienne poudrerie offriront de
nombreuses occasions de promenade aux
habitants de la seine-saint-denis
parmi les aménagements de ce parc
une originalité la présence de potagers
scolaire et de jardins familiaux 80 au
total ils peuvent être loués 500 francs
l'année
pas n'importe quel jardinier
une piste cyclable le long du canal de
l'ourcq permettra de rejoindre paris à
vélo ou à pied maillon supplémentaire
d'une ceinture verte autour de la
capitale
ces deux parcs sevran et jardy place
l'arbre aux portes de la ville basse des
haras de jardy que nous donc quitté à
auteuil aka pas alors nous allons sauter
duras tiercé demain je crois qu'il ya
non partant il y aura donc dix sept
chevaux départ c'est exactement
mais avant de vous parler ce tiercé cela
je voudrais vous rappeler que dimanche
prochain se courra le prix du président
de la république oui qui sera le dernier
tiercé d'obstacles du dimanche avant la
réouverture de l'hippodrome de longchamp
diable de porto sans doute oui je pense
il ya beaucoup de très bons schumann des
toits en feuilles
enfin le tiercé de mai ne manque pas
d'intérêt puisqu'il se va se courir dans
le pli gerald de rochefort qui réunit
les meilleurs chevaux de 4 ans
spécialiste des dix-sept chevaux
s'aligneront au départ des 3600 mètres
pour essayer d'enlever le prix de 300
mille francs offerts aux gagnants jean
paul gallorini l'entraîneur bien connu
engagé trop chaud donc grande attaque le
favori voici l'analyse de leur chambre
en a le plus besoin de le présenter un
c'est le meilleur ce chef de file
il est non seulement bon mais il est
régulier les généreux et il fait que
progresser
alors comment voulez-vous moi je suis
très confiant il va gagner ensuite en
moselle
hebbadj à lui c'était une qualité un peu
en dessous qui va courir en progrès sur
sa course de rentrée dont il est second
du tiercé du pet seconde grande ac
monique andron est encore un peu tendre
pour une course comme ça il a été ce
troisième d'un tiercé il peut bien
courir pour une place sauf incident
cette course ne peut échapper à grande à
qui sera la base de ma sélection ensuite
en jesse son compagnon d'écurie en
deuxième position et puis maritime moore
qui a considéré comme le deuxième traque
de sa génération a pris grande ac
nicandro ce manque un peu de métier mais
il est très doué tout comme le ronde
jambes d'ailleurs qui n'en est qu'à son
quatrième parcours à auteuil massi des
eaux est très régulier dans ses
performances
il peut enlever une épreuve de ce genre
wolton avait des crampes
la dernière fois qu'il a couru mais
cette fois si tout va bien on peut lui
faire confiance
notez bien leur numéro 1 3 2 17 9 8 11
et 4
et voilà nous verrons demain soir si
vous avez eu raison au fait si vous
regarder avec attention les hit parades
du disque en france vous allez trouver à
la première place à la bâche ou alain
bashung c'est un garçon qui est né dans
l'est de la france il ya une trentaine
d'années l'an passé après quelques
années de vaches maigres d'ailleurs au
gaby c'est un succès énorme l'avait
propulsé sur le devant de la scène à la
bashung c'est de la passion pour le rock
n roll de l'humour est bien sûr beaucoup
de talent et cet été mais il va laisser
à peu tomber la chanson arabe al lui
fait jouer le rôle du christ dans un
film co produit par antenne 2 le
cimetière des voitures la passion de
jésus-christ transposer au xxème siècle
dans un casse de voitures à la bâche ou
alain vachon 33 ans l'alsacien chanteur
de rock n roll
alain bashung gravitent dans le monde de
la chanson depuis 12 ans déjà avec des
hauts et des bas des galas des galères
mais la passion est restée la même
l'humour aussi sa grande qualité juste
récompense l'année dernière le succès
est arrivé avec cette api et sa nouvelle
chanson vertige de l'amour g déjà
allègrement dans les hit parades
c'est assez difficile justement
d'arriver à quelque chose de très très
simple et qui a plusieurs sens quoiqu'il
soit qu'ils soient drôles bronze et tu
lis en admettait chst bon c'est assez
c'est assez bizarre quand même
c'est partout les gens très clair et
c'est voulu parce que ça vient du fait
que j'ai pas envie de m'ennuyer
j'apprends lui de d'un soir à l'autre
j'ai envie de chanter ça de manière
différente
comme il ya plusieurs sens d'un soir à
l'autre je peux chanter la chanson
complètement différemment si aujourd'hui
je pense pas qu'on puisse en plus faire
de très très bonnes choses pendant 40
ans les beatles ont bien fait s'arrêter
je crois parce que ils avaient tellement
concentré de bonnes choses pendant un
laps de temps
ensuite il serait peut être répétée ou
ça aurait été beaucoup moins intéressant
quand vous il est génial pendant 40 ans
je comprends
qu'est ce que vous allez faire vous
après alors
j'ai parié toit de choses qui
m'intéressent
bon juste devant nous
une musique de film
et comme tout va très vite alain bashung
rockeur va devenir alain bashung
comédien fernando arrabal en effet la
choisit pour incarner le christ dans un
film qu'il va tourner cet été
le cimetière des voitures un film co
produit par antenne 2 et pense que cette
voie si si si ensorcelante et même temps
si attendrissante
si désespérée d eva joly n'avait pas une
note et je me suis dit que c'était la
révélation puisque j'avais commencé ce
film est démuni c'est qui va pouvoir
ainsi c'est quand même extraordinaire
effet faire la patiente aujourd'hui au
21ème siècle qui va pouvoir le faire et
j'ai écouté ses ouailles sol inanimé
suivi il faut absolument qu'ils aient
payé tout cet homme dont il fit trouver
vachon dans les films et qui voudrait
que nous allons commencer à tourner ton
personnage et ses lectrices de
finalement sa famille c
c'est l'homme qui est à travers son art
tonnard total on va essayer de faire les
biens il va leur donner l'espoir
tout me tout le choix parce que c'est en
fait mon monde mon boulot de ressentir
les choses et des îles les catalyseurs
un peu puis les de faire une espèce de
petite chanson comme ça sur une
impression que j'ai vu c'est normal ils
vont considérer comme un poète
non je me considère comme un type qu'il
ressent les choses qui a envie de les
raconter qui a besoin de qu'elle ait
besoin de faire un peu ce métier pour
essayer de parce qu'il arrive et
peut-être peut-être pas à communiquer ce
qu'ils avaient envie de communiquer
autrement tout simplement avec une
espèce de sensibilité à part et avec une
guitare électrique en plus voilà c'est
pas un complot doubleuse à
genève
vendeurs de briques de la victoire de la
france il y avait aussi une grande
course cycliste aujourd'hui une
classique il s'agissait de milan san
remo et c'est le belge fons de wolf qui
l'a emporté devant un autre belge roger
de vlaeminck
aujourd'hui il a fait à peu près beau
sur l'ensemble du territoire je crois le
rôle reste que ce bouton de printemps va
continuer à écouter mais malheureusement
pour le premier dimanche
voilà nous voilà enfin ce premier
dimanche de printemps il ya une légère
aggravation avec quelques pluies qui
traverseront le pays d'ouest en est
précédée d'éclaircies et suivi des merci
tout de même un coup d'oeil sur les
températures d'aujourd'hui très agréable
il faut le dire des températures
printanières les voies siècle même bien
vous des 20° observé partout c'était
donc un avant goût et même un bon goût
du printemps
alors demain une petite aggravation
pourquoi nous allons voir sur la carte
que voici une ligne ici traversera le
pays d'ouest en est situé à peu près ici
vers midi une heure de l'après-midi
avant du soleil après retour des
éclaircies progressivement sur l'ouest
et vous voyez une autre ligne de nuages
ici qui donnera quelques pluies
cette fois-ci lundi alors n'allons pas
si loin voyons déjà la carte un peu plus
précise pour demain et vous le voyez
bien cette ligne de nuages
elle est ici le matin sera des flandes
et des ardennes jusqu'à l'aquitaine à
midi donc dans cette position le soir
elle atteindra l'est du pays avec
l'envoyé de belgique merci attendu ici
et là-bas le retour progressif des
éclaircies et du soleil avec tout de
même encore quelques petites averses et
puis un vent assez fort de sud ouest sur
les côtes de l'aquitaine et de la manche
et de la mer du nord les températures
pour demain nord centre et sud à bord
l'honneur voyez aggrave le matin 8 10
degrés également l'après midi 15 16
degrés on va voir les régions du centre
maintenant très peu de changements en
fait par rapport aux températures
d'aujourd'hui extrêmement douce agréable
dans le sud encore plus voyez donc une
journée de printemps avec simplement un
petit parapluie dans la poche pour ce
dimanche 22 mars qui sera la sainte les
a si je ne me trompe
voilà alors quand même beaucoup d'oeufs
de lait en france voilà cette édition de
20 heures est maintenant terminée à
23h20 c'est girard us qui vous
présentera note
dernier journal quant à moi je vous
retrouve doit à 12h45 bonne soirée à
demain